[Music]
just differently there's a lot of
[Music]
speakers also boxers so he's like you
know you said action and you're still
talking about the Bulls literally yelled
it already
oh I did I didn't like all the termites
to tore down the house the way they did
you see what are you serious news are
you serious I can't believe the house
fell because the termites they should
have got inspector the beginning you
would termites okay submitted by Bob
here all day mafia
are you here with I'm trying ok I'll
practice I'll practice it is lack condom
alright I'll practice before I come an
HOA tried to find a resident after her
cat left a funny outline in the parking
lot Oh hard an HOA HOA tried to find a
resident after her car that's a funny
outline in the parking lot oh is it a
dick shape I should did donuts with
their tires like oh I just ruined all
the parking lines
mmm that did that I'm a high school you
want ok it was a dick shape telling oh
let me claim it's not really a dick she
let you want it's dirty it looks like a
fire hydrant
yeah it looks like a dog bone or a dog
bone there was a tea party yes I was
leaking that much oil no this is a snowy
day
they just left after it snowed right and
then that's when someone took a photo
and a complaint to HOA about this and
saying like think of the children are
you serious
you know it doesn't but that's just how
ridiculous like it when people go out of
their way and they don't realize how
[ __ ] sexual their thoughts are and
they think everyone else does I don't
like I'm appalled do you see this how
dare you make this in the shape of a
dick like no one's not no one even
thought about Dave yeah I will now every
time I eat tabouleh though so if woman
named Katherine she's she she shared her
story because she horny no she's getting
accused alright so this woman named
Katherine shared her story on reddit
under the subreddit [ __ ] HOA and um and
so she was just saying that money
separated yeah there's so many sub
reddits like for everything there's even
a JK film subreddit that's more
understandable but [ __ ] hosp funny oh
I used to hate HOA and then I realize I
really am thankful for the hall monitors
because they'll do the work that I don't
do I mean you need that HOA unless they
don't do [ __ ] you know but but it's
mainly for situations like this like
they were trying to find Katherine a
hundred dollars because it violated HOA
rules of displaying offensive images or
slogan oh don't think things so sweet
hypersensitive fools
I like our HOA fee yeah so she opened
her email she saw that you liked her a
Joey I like ours
Oh the Utah yard clean you don't even
deal with clean roads he's trying to get
you brownie points right now you're
brewing it cut me bright you trying to
get HOA brownie points but when you
watch this fine I know they watch so I
like Rachel in it no so then you're
telling me that other people agreed with
this with cook they had to all agree
exactly yes so that's that there's that
many wrong morons the email said your
car specifically the Honda
left this offensive image on the ground
after you left [ __ ] Honda's man I
believe you will see why we had
complaints about it one of our residents
took the photo and reported it to us out
of concern for a younger resident Wow
even wrote this I can't believe that's a
topic of discussion for their monthly
Thursday night meeting did you see that
dig on the ground to say where this was
it was a black day if it was a white
dick I'd be okay but you put that
monster black dick there I think that's
what how are you drooling all over the
place yes so then she she just like
started laughing but then obviously she
got angry because they're trying to get
a hundred dollars out of her so then she
said that dick ulis yes so then she
emailed them back saying that she will
get lawyers involved if they don't
dismiss this because according to the to
the laws earth sorry the rules it has to
be intentional obviously yeah they think
that she turned on the car and she's
like I know I'm missing away 30 seconds
cuz it's gonna melt it into a dish like
this snow is coming down perfectly for
me to make my dick art under my car
that's a talent that's really hard to do
back off
yeah so then that's one HOA pretty much
backed off cuz then she was telling you
I'm like this is gonna cost you guys a
lot of money too for us to go through
court because obviously I want to go to
the Hou meeting cuz I want to I want to
meet idiots like this and just hear
their thoughts and how they came to this
conclusion it really does that's the
stupidest [ __ ] so done that'll piss
you off really yeah because I love
stupid there's no logic yeah that's why
it's so funny and then you get to [ __ ]
with them and troll them but the harp
even though you're trolling man part is
it's against you so you're at the
meeting and then they're trying to
figure how to get your car towed and
your how to understand wait so my car
got impounded because of your stupid
thoughts you know I [ __ ] how do I get my
car back or how do i how do I understand
this you guys have had your cars oh no
oh I can imagine people in this
situation some people you just have the
strong arm dude but then you you
actually even if it was it wouldn't hold
in court don't look [ __ ] ridiculous
dirty but you already walk-in with
winning though so not one person was
like you guys
she just parked like that's why it so
funny it's like a [ __ ] Town Hall full
of idiots it's like everyone's a town
drunk well you know also also the thing
is my HOA meetings like I never go I
feel like I never go young people right
in in my little gated community I used
to live and went to the HOA meetings
it's prob like just a really old
annoying like super just not
understanding what's going on thinking
they know what's going on people at
these meetings thinking they're so
important you know it's a hassle to like
there's people at our place that got
their cars towed so imagine like you
wake up one morning and you're in a rush
to go to work and you come out in your
car's not even there in your life but
and then you can't just meet them but no
you got to meet me in three weeks that's
when the HOA meeting is so the HOA
people told your neighbors cars yeah it
big you gotta talk cuz it's a door zone
that you're not supposed to park in but
everyone parks there so someone's car
got towed so just that it's just a house
like my car's never got towed but I
could just didn't put myself in that
person's shoes like you're you're used
to your regular routine life right thank
you a lot this many times this much time
to get in the car to go to work and then
you come out and your car's gone and
you're like [ __ ] with Allah who the [ __ ]
taught even contact that's [ __ ] crazy
cuz I would never do that cuz I would be
like you know I live in this
neighborhood with you right I know
exactly yeah yeah yeah I will [ __ ] you
someone got a letter that they were
about to get fine because like with HOA
rules you have a certain amount of time
that you can leave your Christmas lights
on after Christmas and they so happen to
have a welcome mat or like a doormat
trees or something I've just had yea
pine trees oh my god you get fine
because they're like you need to put the
[ __ ] away and they're like wait doesn't
say anything about Christmas and why do
you even care about my doormat these are
the pine police they're the it's
Halloween you need to have a
jack-o'-lantern on that [ __ ] floor
mat thank you very might have a monopoly
on [ __ ] Christmas
pine trees are everywhere yeah no they
wanted it they assumed that it was for
Christmas yeah do they go to the [ __ ]
forest and go it's not Christmas
[ __ ]
your place are you ready only I was at
our place because we have a community
Facebook where we all talk there patty
do there
who that person is cuz you just [ __ ]
them up I just hear this stories from
her come on II want to get a ball so
that's how you say that you love them
and I'm like you don't even know I love
you guys playing the game I know the
game yeah my HOA ruining the game the
game I guarantee you no matter what you
guys do they're not gonna say [ __ ] every
Thursday morning you get beat up in your
[ __ ] driveway by two men they all
give me high fives you know that Korean
dudes always come by oh you do Taekwondo
I'm like something like that good it's
like on the other side of your area like
you want the cool side yeah you may be
everyone there's like nice we're not on
the cool side because you say we can't
park our cars on our own driveway we
have to be using that garage
this little boy dojo no it's not it's
not so the way that our HOA does it is
you're supposed to park your cars in the
garage first and then maybe you can park
on your driveway but they don't want
anyone parking on the driveway so if you
have four cars you're allowed to have
two cars in your driveway if the other
two cars already in the garage but if
not your garage your driveway how do
they know right oh interesting so if
they know that your [ __ ] garage is
empty and you have your car on your
driveway they can my stoppage in there
yeah you know what I did you need to use
that at for your car so you know what I
did how's that [ __ ] no one
follows this rule so while I was walking
my dogs
I started snapping pictures of every
single house that was violating the same
rule but while I was snapping pictures I
was like [ __ ] I can't even leave I'm
wasting my time doing this [ __ ] but I
have to get evidence in case they start
filing a court thing against me it's
like well that stuff does not sound fun
it sounds fun when a HOA accuses you of
leaving dick prints on the floor and you
go to the HOA meeting to hear what their
thoughts were yeah that's why I call
like this to our agent I love our HOA
yeah me too I love I love Mary Choi
[ __ ] boring ass [ __ ] yeah nothing to
better do with your [ __ ] life you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] I thought I
recently received a letter from the HOA
at our place and like Casey and I we're
renting so I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
what you guys do
no blue hair oh no and then so they were
things there's a saying something like I
forgot how they worded it but they were
pretty much worrying in a way I
passive-aggressive as a mother so
passive-aggressive but the whole point
of the letter is that they're trying to
reelect like or they're trying to elect
mute like a completely new HOA board the
way board exactly and but the way like
they were throwing the other guys under
the bus it was [ __ ] petty it's like a
Republicans and Democrat war within
Europe yeah it was funny I shouldn't say
oh and for you kids HOA is the
homeowners association they're in charge
of like the property that you're we had
a we had like anonymous like HOA letters
telling us we can't like park in front
of the house and all this stuff and then
they try to psych codes of like city
parking rules it can't be over 48 hours
and this and that and they were
highlighting parts that were so [ __ ]
bogus I was just reading this like this
is not gonna fly in court dude they're
just trying to scare us
yeah they would write us letters and
[ __ ] and I'm all like this is nothing
like I could leave the car park there
and move it to the other side of the
road it's not gonna do anything but I
also believe in like there's city
culture like wherever you go there's
that culture of that city in the
majority will rule so like if you want
to be kind of crazy and have parties all
night just live in El Monte right like
but then if you if you want to be
eccentric than different - you live in
Hollywood but you can't be the oddball
in whatever area you're in like if it's
gonna be full of young families you know
like alright in you're throwing parties
yeah yeah yeah we're like if it's a
senior community like you don't want to
be the only one that's young and loud
and doing [ __ ] like so I think it's all
about that
[Music]